mal bitte Sandra und lad das auf only
Fans hoch wir machen mal wieder
entbannungsanträge oh mein Gott das
haben wir so lange nicht mehr gemacht um
es euch mal ganz kurz zu erklären wenn
sich Personen bei mir im Chat daneben
Verhalten beleidigen spammen irgende
Scheiße schreiben dann werden sie
gebannt man hat aber die Möglichkeit
einen entbannungsantrag zu stellen um
mir und den Mod zu zeigen e guck mal du
mir leid oder ich habe es aus dem dem
Grund geschrieben oder ich verstehe es
nicht oder keine Ahnung was und das
schauen wir uns jetzt heute mal an und
schauen ob wir einige Leute wieder frei
geben oder gebannt lassen komm wir
machen es mal so ich mache mal Emote
Chat only und ihr schickt jetzt immer
einen einen grünen Emote wenn ihr findet
die Person sollte wieder entsperrt
werden und ihr schickt einen roten Emote
irgendwas rotes einfach ist egal was
wenn ihr denkt die Person sollte
geblockt bleiben let's
go geh Eier bei deiner Mutter lecken B
ich ma keine Scheiße
mehr ablehnen Marie K Trip hat auf jeden
Fall schon einiges hier geschrieben 7
drit war s schon am Start vor mehr als
ein halben Jahr wollte Zahnspange
bekommen sagt das Creeper
bkenkäferer du bist echt meine Kindheit
la die Hexe direkt nicht runter ihrcke
pisst euch la die ein ach du scheiße
also das mit dem war nicht mit Absicht
ich wollte das nicht schreiben ich
wollte Hilfiger
sch Tomy Hilfiger weil ich den und seine
Klamotten superfeier und gerade
Klamotten davon in meinem Schrank
gesehen
auf gar keinen Fall auf die ein hi hi hi
töten Bücher JJ
HS ich schwöre habe das Wort aus
Versehen geschrieben tut mir leid Sub
wär bereit wenn ich von dir nicht
mindestens ein Dreier Sub giift hier
sehe an die Community dann wirst du
nächste Woche wieder gesperrt ich habe
scharze Kinder in
[Musik]
meinem ma Abschuss hier hat jemand ander
Mailadresse ich wusste nicht dass man
wegen sowas gebannt wir ich schau Stream
se einer Ewigkeit bin sehr traurig bitte
entpannen nee diger wir haben schon
gesagt dass es nicht cool war das zu
leen klar jetzt ist es eh zu spät und zu
zu jetzt ist dumm so se hat eine neue
E-Mailadresse aber abblindung Sinn h ja
obviously geschrieben habe Screenshot
und hat dann reingeschickt ich weiß er
hat hier zwei Monats Abonnent aber das
macht man nicht diger das ist dann auch
egal finde ich geht gar
nicht er war brutal Prime folgt mir mal
folgt mir mal alle auf Twitch danke es
tut mir leid dass ich Werbung für meinen
Kanal gemacht habe ich werde es nie
wieder tun nein rot dein einziger
Verlauf in meinem in meinem Chat ist
Werbung nur Werbung auch hier die ganze
Zeit normal mitgeschrieben jetzt 12 11
mach ein water MLG alte vi blaaa lauter
bin 11 ja ist halt ich habe auch Spaß
mal etwas geschrieben und Twitch hat mir
direkt gesperrt könntet ihr mich
entsperren bitte na ja du hast halt
geschrieben dass du 11 bist und der
Grund ist below Twitch minimum age man
darf auf Twitch einfach nicht in dem
Alter unterwegs sein das ist einfach
verboten die Sache ist du wolltest
wahrscheinlich schreiben du bist 11 m
groß und daher würde ich jetzt aufheben
okay ganz viele Emotes irg reingespamam
bra bitte hensoh jemand hat mich
beleidigt und ich habe halt zurück
beleleidigt er hat eine Nachricht bisher
geschrieben meem ganzen Chat eine
Nachricht das tut mir leid was ich
geschrieben habe ich weiß leider nicht
was aber ich hoffe dass ich wieder be
den Chat teilnehmen kann würde mich
freuen nee ne nee diger eine Nachricht
und das ist direkt eine Beleidigung
scheiß Mods beleidigt liebe Mods lieber
Luca es gibt kein Verhalten der Welt was
meine Tat wieder gut macht eigentlich
habe ich größ Respekt vor all den Mods
weil ihr macht echt eine super Arbeit
ich wünsche ich könnte euch beweisen
dass ich mich benehmen kann es tut mir
unendlich leid dass ich das geschrieben
habe bitte gebt mir eine zweite Chance
dit ich es euch beweisen kann falls mich
noch mal daneben benehme könnt ihr mich
sofort blocken falls mich nicht
entsperren wollt verstehe ich das die
Sperre wird direkt aufgoben sehr schöner
Text und sorry ihr seid natürlich nicht
scheiße ich kann nicht vorspulen ich
kann nicht vorspulen ich kann nicht
vorspulen ich kann nicht vorspulen ich
kann nicht vorspulen er schreibt nur er
kann nicht vorspulen die dummen
Arschgesichter ich wollte nur testen ich
wollte nur testen was denn das oh ich
kaufe mal eine Waffe ich erschieß mal
einen Typen hat geklappt ist tot ich
gehe nicht in Knast wollt nur testen
funktioniert gut gemacht ableen soll die
Dichte Fichte ein Baum werden oder ist
das so ein barding was sagst du zum
neuen GT oh da gibt's bald übrigens
Neuigkeiten mal bitte Sandra und lad das
auf only
Fans bin gerade erst neu und wollte
wissen wofür man gebannt wird verpiss
dich ich wollte wissen wofür ich gebannt
werde ja exakt dafür und das bleibst du
auch Eisen hat der prank mit dem Zombie
funktioniert safe einfach die Wahrheit
kann ich Bann bekommen kann ich bitte
endbann
werden nur damit ich dich jetzt entban
und du wieder gebannt werden willst ne
ne du bleibst schön gebannt Spiel nicht
mit dem Feuer wenn du dich nicht
verbrennen willst kleiner paderban
ist halt
[Musik]
so allein dafür will ich ihn eigentlich
am liebsten endanen so do habe ich heute
noch kein Malal gelacht ablehnen bumse
deine Mutter tut mir wirklich leid ich
werde es nie wieder tun was meine Mutter
bumsen oder das hier reinschreiben wie
war in dein Chat bisher du hast nur die
uh reingeschrieben h hast du nurpam ja
dicker schei ablehen J discord Ferien
Laa J watchtime könnt ihr mich bannen
sehr gute modarbeit ja du bleibst auch
gebannt min jung sexy Sizilien kommt mal
was spannendes kommt noch mal was
spannendes J mean will never
ahen diger auch dieses kommt noch mal
was spannendes das ist so das lässt ein
selbst als Streamer ich will mich
eentlich nicht so sehen weil dafür gehe
ich viel zu selten live aber solche
Kommentare lassen einen selbst als
Creator als Youtuber als keine Ahnung
was immer so dumm vorkommen weil ich mir
so denke diger ich mache das worauf ich
Bock habe wenn euch das nicht gefällt
dann es gibt ganz ganz viele andere
Streams dann schaut euch das an oder ein
anderes Youtube Video oder so aber das
dann zu kritisieren was man macht das
verstehe ich immer nicht weil es es
wirkt so weiß ich nicht es wirkt so wie
also wir sind hier im Internet diger
wenn du was anderes sehen willst oder
machen willst dann hast du genügend
Möglichkeiten alle aus hypixel und dann
Party habe alles verloren call my baby
as sorry dass ich das geschrieben habe
es war sehr unüberlegt von mir und ich
wollte einfach nur testen wie die Mods
drauf reagieren elich fah ich ja la
Übels und wollte fragen ob ich wier Chat
teilnehmen kann und wollte mich noch mal
herzlich entschuldigen dafür dass ich
dum gehandelt habe herzlich drei oder
vier mal entschuldigt deswegen würde ich
ihn eigentlich das durchgehen lassen ich
weiß ihr schreibt alle rot aber wenn du
dich drei oder vier Mal entschuldigst
und so ein Text schreibst dann ist es
eigentlich auch ist meinersicht nach
okay du h dich du tut mir leid wollte
nur Aufmerksamkeit Laa hat den größten
stimmt zwar aber du wirst abgelehnt KCK
hi Youtube s du Maschine mansandra Olaf
Eierlecken hallo laserlaca ich weiß zwar
nicht wirklich warum ich gesperrt wurde
da ich meistens lach emojis wenn dann in
den Chat schreibe und sonst eigentlich
nichts schreibe außer wenn etwas lustig
ist und an den und hoffe du kannst
verzeihen und mich entsperren Sperre
aufheben klar kommst wieder rein min hi
moin Leute hi was hältst du von einem
Server Community was hält von ein für
Community ich habe dieses übersteuerte
Musikvideo was gerade ein herzenf
verursacht hat geklippt soll ich dir
schicken ne danke ich werde in zwe
Wochen 13 und habe alleile soweit es
geht durchgespielt AGs of service was
auch immer ich gemacht habe ich
verspreche ich mache es nie wieder ja
ich werde in zwei Wochen 13 Hunde
besitzen meinst du wahrscheinlich
deswegen würde ich auch hier die Sperre
aufheben und Glückwunsch zu den Tieren
ich hoffe du wirst sich gut um die
kümmern letzte einbannungsantrag für
heute diese Person hat ganz ganz viel
bisher reingeschrieben in den Chat und
dann du wix Geburt ist an sich keine
Beleidigung jeder ist eine wichsgeburt
jeder kommt aus Wichse ey ich habe nur
das geschrieben was du gesagt hast und
du hast das selber gesagt dass alle eine
wichgeburt sind also es war so unnötig
bitte wieder entban also das finde ich
blöd es war so unnötig weil du wurdest
ja gebannt weil es eine Beleidigung ist
so wiche ist ja so ein cursew so vom
Ding her an sich ist wixgeburt keine
Beleidigung ich finde jeder sollte
wixgeburt schreiben dürfen genauso wie
spermkind das hört sich so nach einer
Beleidigung an aber es sind ja
eigentlich keine Beleidigung deswegen
hebe ich deine Sperre auf und Du bist
wieder in der Luk mein lieber
Freund ja wir sind einfach befreundet so
Freunde das waren die
entbannungsanträge ich hoffe dass die
Leute die entbannt wurden ihre Lektion
gelernt haben und in Zukunft wissen wie
sie sich hier im Chat zu verhalten
haben
[Musik]